wouldn't make sense to at least include
that if you're gonna keep all the
daredevil events canon
it would make sense to do that but you
know i mean maybe he's just a big dude
with obscene strength have you ever been
punched by a guy that fat
if he gets hit through the car have you
been punched by a guy that
you're too many bad guys all the time
it's the only people i fight
[Laughter]
[Music]
start over until we watch the new rock
stars break down today for the hawkeye
finale sure there's gonna be some good
things to say especially after hearing
eric boss voice some of his opinions
about the fidelity as well anywho guys
i'm sure either way this is gonna cause
us to appreciate that finale even more
so i had some messages yesterday on my
social media about people asking where i
got this hawkeye shirt we got it from
the epic hero shop over at new rockstars
yeah this one is about to go in the
laundry basket but um i wanted to show
it here right now and then we got these
two from there as well so yeah they got
great merch great merch they didn't ask
us to plug it i'll just kill two birds
with one stone by answering it here
let's watch this welcome back to new
rockstars i'm eric voss and this is a
breakdown of hawkeye episode six the
series finale so this is christmas a
title that reminds us that this show is
at its heart a christmas treat the title
also citing john lennon yoko ono's happy
xmas war is over and that song's
children's choir much like the angelic
voices of this episode
[Music]
interesting you might have missed and
heads up i am going to include spoilers
for both hawkeye and spiderman no way
home the episode opens with the kings
wilson
returning in the same delivery as the
character in the netflix marvel
daredevil this first shot we see of him
is actually his cane an interesting
parallel very first shot of charlie cox
matt murdock and spider-man no way home
came first and as fisk approaches the
camera shoots him from below and then
shoots eleanor down from above and then
throughout the scene continues to frame
kingpin huge from the circle that is
cool
and then when it cuts back to eleanor
she is small in frame on the other side
of the desk just some forced perspective
to heighten the size differential and to
make kingpin all the more intimidating
there's also a reflection of this in the
door behind eleanor giving us the sense
that he is surrounding her that was one
thing i really did appreciate about this
episode was how they managed to capture
the size of kingpin like the last
episode ended with that silhouette of
kingpin over the city and then when you
introduce him in this very first scene
there is something about his scale and
especially concerning the fact that this
episode really makes him stronger
physically stronger than he already has
been that size really does pack a punch
eleanor begins we've had a good
relationship haven't we wilson
yes
yes kingpin has gotten good at reading
people and d'onofrio twitches his eye
from the very beginning of the scene
until it just lashes out in a rage by
the scene's end the twitching eye also
foreshadows his off-screen fate when he
is shot by maya lopez but as in the
daredevil comics we'll probably just
walk away blinded there's a shot of
midtown midfield that shows the hell's
kitchen neighborhood the domain of
kingpin kind of the heart of kingpin's
grip on the city and of course the
stomping grounds of matt burdock and you
can see some industrial steam blocking
out the view of the skyline but there's
actually a new tower added between the
empire state building and the bank of
america tower on the right side
and those really really tall central
park towers on the left i don't think
this tower exists in real life and yes
it is interesting that it is masked by
steam here this is roughly where
avengers tower used to be located that
tower was always cgi'd over the real
life met life building which is located
beside grand central station however
this episode actually shows us the
metlife building later on and a shot of
comcast tower aka 30 rock but in that
shot there is that large blue tower
right beside it that i also don't think
exists in real life so the mcu might
have actually relocated former avengers
tower slightly in the city's geography
and the steam back in that establishing
shot makes me wonder if something was
being masked from this building because
we know in far from home spider-man
sailed right through a new atrium that
was constructed in that tower by its new
occupant this series doesn't really
confirm the answer to that but it could
be fisk tower or the fantastic four
baxter building
bravo that's a beautiful one well done
that's a beautiful catch a whole [ __ ]
ton of buildings in that shot and you're
like what is that do you look at every
building and say did you get a thomas
guy and like look at the entire layout
of the city cross-reference all the
buildings built however the hell did you
catch that a lot of times i i feel like
are we over reading into this building
sometimes i think that but the fact that
it is covered by steve and it is
something that is not within new york
city unless we're all wrong
you get the blame but if those were
wrong then they would have to be covered
that up for a very specific reason
that's where the mutants come from
that's where wolverine is it's a mutant
that's cranking about save your school
for the gifted right there in the center
the big building that you can visit maya
lopez meets with kazzy and kingpin who
now changed into a red hawaiian shirt
his exact outfit from the cover of the
spider-man comic family business notice
how fisk only knows certain words in asl
i always taught you to keep a
low profile
he knows a low profile in sign language
probably a recurring reminder that he
has repeated since she was young maya
claims to have dropped her ronin pursuit
but kingpin does not buy it and notice
how his eye twitch returns and he tells
cazzy the people
need to be reminded
that the city belongs to me
echoing the kind of words he would use
in the netflix daredevil show i wanted
to make this city
something better
than it is
something beautiful
you took that away from me
this is my city
my family you know i just thought about
what if they're building because they
have daredevil in spider-man right and
spider-man's gonna be in his college
years now or he's probably gonna be more
street level so what if charlie cox
could be some type of partner or a
father figure of sorts and it's building
to a showdown where they have to go up
against kingpin oh that would be how
sweet would that be so
that would that would take care of
everything you would get your badass
team up fighting obviously but then you
know matt murdock has tons of relatable
experience that peter could benefit from
yeah because he's been like an arch
nemesis for both daredevil and
spider-man in so many ways then a
montage shows clint and kate assembling
a whole bunch of trick arrows one of
many christmas movie homages in this
episode recalling that planning montage
and home alone you'll notice they have
another pim arrowhead but whereas the
previous one glowed blue the color for
pimp discs that in large stuff this one
has a red interior the color of pin
particles and discs that shrink things
and along with too dangerous the other
labels read airbag freeze flash bomb
icebreaker all things we see used in the
final battle that guy's leg
wait a minute i just catch another cgi
shot look at clint's face i only catch
these on new rockstars breakdowns am i
right
that looks like a cgi face doesn't it
look at that face it could be yeah it
could be warping a little bit it looks
like a warped face i don't know why you
would need to cj that but you might be
right i mean it looks yeah i ca i can't
quite tell but you looks digital i don't
know maybe i'm wrong either way that one
guy's losing that leg you tell me if i
broke uses electromagnetism to attract
metal which is similar text how cap
would retract his shield to his arm and
age of ultron then a series of stark
arrowheads that are tipped with red and
gold of course iron man's colors ones
that were probably designed by tony
stark for clint kate recalls the episode
one prologue when she saw clint fighting
chitari without any superpowers or tech
unlike iron man in that battle you
showed me that being a hero isn't just
for people who can fly or shoot lasers
out of their hands it's for anyone but i
guess being a hero is for people using
the weapons built by the guys who
see a caravan of trust of road trucks
pulling up to 30 rock
[Music]
yes once again we hear dance of the
sugar plum fairy from tchaikovsky's
nutcracker and that classical music
evokes the way hans gruber's crew was
scored with ode to joy as they arrived
in die hard
trust the brothers are just as menacing
more menacing ivan also says red one in
position like he's part of the red
squadron in star wars elena arrives to
the party in a green coat another
production design element pulled from
home alone in which several shots of
that movie have both red and green
somewhere in the frame like the
mcallister's year-round yet still
christmasy wallpaper which they did to
give that movie an all-time christmasy
feel this episode often does the same
thing not just with christmas
decorations everywhere literally in the
costuming of red and
tracks yeah good cats random background
set decorations clint spots sniper in
the champagne and he quickly uses the
serving platter to deflect the bullet
and all hell breaks loose kate boards
the elevator with elena and wrestles
with her until the top tears away to her
new purple hawkeye archer top which i
just really appreciate because it was
the elena's probing interrogation
episode 5 that helped kate realize why
exactly she wanted to be an avenger and
in another christmas movie homage kate
pulls a buddy the elf on the elevator
[Music]
come on that is so pretty
like a christmas tree
is russian for [ __ ] kate chases elena
in a cool lateral tracking shot through
the office space reminding us of the
awesome that's what i said
and this means that on the hawkeye set
they likely had to build a whole set
with a dollhouse opening to roll in
front of but they do conceal a cut as
they move from the kitchen into the
lobby and here this firm is called
tanner d's and associates olivia tanner
was the set decoration coordinator for
the show courtney deez was set to
graduation p.a that is awesome the
marvel shows will work in the names of
the cast and crew yeah visual details
appreciate it
elena's widow staff to knock it out the
window and then they end up
complimenting each other as creepy baby
santa oh
elena anchors herself with that
repelling line and the camera reorients
with her as she scales down the building
that is a fantastic shot the empire
state building is framed perfectly
behind her and then kate has to jump out
a window the same way she saw hawkeye do
when she was a kid but miraculously
lands unharmed
that is cool because i was picking up on
parallels for the first episode and this
one with like kate shooting the arrow
knocking down the christmas tree doing
better than she did with the clock when
she fights the track suits how the first
time she did she was like unconfident a
little messy this time she's really
confident and is more calculated and
better there with the shot of her
jumping out of the window i didn't even
think about oh yeah she saw that with
clint that's one of the first things she
ever saw when she was a child now this
is really her arc of becoming the
hawkeye yeah and then she did that with
him in the middle of it you know so you
can chart the sort of passing of that
baton yeah
i think you're reading so much into it
jack saves her proving he really is just
a naive dummy who loves swords cool as
the tracks
he's got an opinion
which was the same device that clint
used on the outriders who chased him in
end game and then clint tries to pull a
john mclean out the window but he ends
up more like the wet bandits home alone
whose zipline also breaks and then he
ends up stuck in the tree where he meets
the cutest owl
cute for now this owl is a reference to
an owl that was found in the 30 rock
christmas tree last christmas
cute owl named rocky kate throws a trick
just like mcallister does to break the
window and trip the alarm to the toy
store in home alone too and she also
stands on that big keyboard just like
tom hanks does advaita shorts and
bigfoot timbers the tree by breaking the
wires and shooting an acid arrow at the
trunk calling back her unintentional
demolition of staintower back in episode
one and as the tree falls you can
actually see that owl flying out of it
on the ice uses a magnetic arrow to
snatch all of their guns and clint
reveals he wore his new suit underneath
his torn shirt a classic superhero
shortcut proving he has come full circle
on that branding issue i wish there was
a little bit more attention put towards
clint in this episode in that regard too
because there was such that fantastic
like diner scene they had where he was
talking about how i'm no hero and he
feels like such a big sense of shame
about himself like he really didn't view
himself in her own life not that i'm
saying clint should walk out and go i'm
a hero
step aside it's fine i am the hawkeye
whatever i have nothing to fear what
target do you have for me today
i'm to say that personally just as a
little preference would have liked a
little bit more emphasis on he really
has accepted the fact that he is indeed
a hero yeah and accentuating that
through the tone and i feel like yeah he
definitely kicks ass but it's in a very
straightforward manner the way the
episode is posed doesn't have to be a
full scene just like one little quirk of
dialogue even with kate being like see
you're a hero shut up kate something
like that you know brandon it keeps it
still quick
then they just unleash all the trick
arrows in the track suits it is awesome
kate once again uses her bow as a
springboard he uses her legs to tackle a
guy the way black widow would do but the
most yeah
of course is that red glowing pim arrow
that shrinks the tresta bro truck what
happens to them now i don't know
i'll tell scott about that yes telling
us that clint might have gotten this
tech from scott directly not hank pym
and that clint in scott's partnership
after civil war continues it's also kind
of a mirroring effect because in civil
war scott he threw a truck during that
airport fight but he used it to make it
larger though and this is reverse where
they take a truck and make it smaller
see the mirroring like contribution and
all rhymes it's lyrical but then the owl
snatches them away in no joke the
captions of this episode label their
squeaky screams as children shouting
this is the most horrific mcu
since darren cross shrunk hank into a
plop of twitching goo so that owl either
fed these tiny humans to its children or
used as talons to crush them and then
pull them apart limb by limb with its
beak marvel please pimp tech deaths are
terrifying and we kind of love them yeah
that is horrific
one
no it's not impossible the first area
you release just has to be wood so when
you release the second one splits it
right up the middle i call [ __ ] i've
tried it well i've done it a few times
but cassie catches the middle arrow the
way loki does in avengers which just
makes me think that this guy has got to
be juiced on something a lot of the
tracksuits are or it could just be the
show suddenly remembered that this
character existed and decided to give
him something to do i mean in this
episode a lot of casual dialogue is not
really 80 yard in you know what i have
to do don't make me do this maya i don't
know it just looks like they had to
reconfigure a lot of this in
post-production to bring many of these
subplots to a close in a sixth episode
eric doesn't review often during the
breakdowns
yeah and you could feel these little
shades of
opinions piercing through what worked
and maybe didn't work for eric as he
tells maya
i guess calling back to william's advice
to maya in episode three but other than
that photo of the three of them together
and then the references to kazi being
his number two we never really feel any
context to william and kazi's
relationship or this callback to make
sense to come from kazi clearly if
rafi's role in this series was super
trimmed down it's a bummer elena asks
clint what happened in the time show
your sister sacrificed herself she saved
the world i'm sorry
you're lying i love the shock
composition with elena because behind
her that fallen christmas tree with all
of its lights looks like infinite
infinity stones that are all out of
focus because she doesn't care about the
dumb rainbow rock stakes that natasha
gave her life over in truth neither does
clint anymore kingpin rips off eleanor's
door literally opening the door to
possibility this time after the netflix
show made him famous for slamming
kartour's clothes kate plunkett
but it has no effect kingpin in the
comics is bulky because of layers of
muscle in a daredevil he wore body armor
but the kingpin of this show is also
super strong he's getting plowed through
windows of buildings he's ripping off
car doors he's punching people across
rooms i'm wondering if this kingpin
strength may also be a factor of a
dosage of some kind of super soldier
serum vince's monoprio recently came out
and he did say directly that this is the
same kingpin from daredevil that this
arc serves as like some type of purpose
for him wanting to regain back his power
which would
line up with that line early on in the
episode of like we need to remind this
city so with that in mind i'm like okay
how how eric just pointed out the fact
that he had body armor before and he is
like obnoxiously strong this time around
they would have to justify it in some
way or maybe not i don't know i
personally feel like they would have to
justify in some ways so so the super
soldier ceremony that's been like a big
part of the mcu in total wouldn't make
sense to at least include that if you're
gonna keep all the daredevil events
canon
it would make sense to do that but you
know i mean maybe he's just a big dude
with obscene strength have you ever been
punched by a guy that fat
if he gets hit through the car
have you been punched by a guy that
you're too many bad guys all the time
it's the only people i fight
[Laughter]
hate notices him adjusting his cuff
links and then yeah he gets rammed into
the toy store and kate bravely engages
this huge man despite his insane
strength he snaps her trick arrows but
then she uses this because she leaps on
his arm where she saw him adjusting the
cuff link and you can see the momentum
that was her objective so then she uses
clint's coin flicking trick to activate
that one magnetic arrow which starts a
chain reaction to the too dangerous one
but also triggers that sonic blast and
that cluster bomb arrow all at once
these all cook fisk and then he lies
motionless and in that shot you can see
the cuff link missing nice great catch
good script supervision the murderer
armand kane iii turn around please yeah
i'm pretty sure this scene was re-shot
as well because the background looks
like a plate the detective's lines are
off-screen and the detective we do see
has just a really weird eye line hey hey
who are you looking at i think eleanor
might also have been reworked production
because we never really see her kill
armond see her kill anyone i'm betting
that there was an alternate ending with
her character maybe her dying instead of
just getting arrested like this i mean
but we also gotta go off of your
previous breakdowns there's red and blue
flashing lights on her face reflective
of spider-man i do like how the police
lights flash red and blue on their faces
the color of the webhead hero that whips
them together spider-man has to be
coming for eleanor eleanor is the next
spider-man villain in spider-man 4. no i
completely agree with you they
definitely rework [ __ ] last minute you
can feel it all the time i do wonder
some of this last-minute rework it was
because they might not have been
confident in getting a season two for
this particular show the only other
thing i could think of was like maybe
vincent d'onofrio wasn't like fully
locked in until late but i don't know i
feel like that's something you would
want to have planned plantations
clint is able to turn elena by repeating
that whistle that she shared with her
sister
[Music]
why did you say that whistle
and clint reveals how natasha told him
about the events in the black widow
prologue escaping ohio on a plane being
separated from elena and doing so he
reverts elena to her american pie
singing innocence before she became a
killer clint apologizes to her and elena
decides to leave probably to pave a
future on some dark avengers or
thunderbolts lineup with val and john
walker and notice how only now it begins
to snow this tells us that the final
scene is spider-man no way home and
which
swings through 30 rock plaza past the
tree while around the same time might
have been a different night because that
tree was still upright and it was fully
snowing in that scene so don't worry we
don't have to look in the background for
peter swinging around here
you're good man
spiderman was busy slank an empty throne
considering how much the tracksuits
self-identified with nutcracker music
you could interpret these as the
tracksuits who now protect an empty
throne at least temporarily empty with
kingpin's latest setback in the next
scene as maya finds him and points a gun
at him sometimes family doesn't
so no corpse no death what happened
snowman in the window what did you see
well yes we do have both a gunshot and a
thud to the ground but notice how
kingpin said eye to eye that has got to
be a nod to the similar moment in the
daredevil comics when daredevil tells
echo about kingpin's lies and echo
shoots kingpin in the face but we later
find out that he's just blinded by this
and he actually later on after that gets
some reconstructive surgery the
reconstructive surgery was a little bit
debated in the comics especially because
it's it's not like he
you know
had some disease or what it's like he
got
shot
superhero story they can do anything
with the technology they have they not
attacked it or something we will see
kingpin in the mcu again but the next
time he will be temporarily blind or
maybe with an eye patch but fully blind
would make him a more interesting foe to
maya lopez in the echo series and of
course the perfect foe to daredevil who
also now joins the mcu clint let's join
him on christmas day
because sitting in that bucket is the
baseball glove that he recovered from
his son during the time heist trial and
end game to prove that things could be
removed from the past and prove that he
could reunite with his family kate
brings the dog along
that's lucky as expected they settled on
the name lucky as the dog is named in
the fraction comics and clint returns
that rolex to laura and on the back is a
shield logo laura's face reflected in
that shield and the number 19 which is a
reference to shield agent 19 the
designation for mockingbird bobby morse
in the comics but in this case the
number for laura barton at least before
she retired this explains laura's
espionage professionalism throughout the
series and makes tony stark's first
words upon meeting laura and age voltron
super ironic this is an agent of some
kind outside clinton barbecue suit and
as they return to the house
brainstorming names for her settling on
the title of hawkeye in the foreground
the archery target comes into frame the
same target from clint's opening scene
in avengers endgame that was the moment
that truly began this final chapter of
clint's journey final we think and now
kate bishop helped bring him home and
then we get a post-credit scene showing
the full save the city song from roger's
musical the conductor is actually cameo
by the composer of that song mark shaman
who wrote the music and the lyrics
alongside scott whitman both of them
long-time broadway girls behind
hairspray and a number of other titles
little new detailer is so good now
performer hits his big note his shield
mike wazowski's the hawkeye performer
who awkwardly has to move out from
behind it but there's also a crazy cut
in this moment where hawkeye goes from
being on cap's left to being right
beside hulk
and loki hold hands oh anytime you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow me rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
goodbye eric that's the end of new rock
stars
i mean
no new rockstar new rockstars is over
they're going out on this one go out on
the highest note possibly yeah wilson
fisk and his poor poor eyes at least in
the duh the some of the direction and
shots in production designed it to make
me appreciate the episode more merry
christmas happy holidays happy hanukkah
happy belated hanukkah happy new year
happy kwanzaa thank you so much for
being part of this channel with us we'll
see you guys soon